da freue ich mich heute morgen zu
sprechen und dass er hier zu mir
gekommen ist vor die grüne
bundesgeschäftsstelle mit jürgen trittin
der nicht nur mitglied der letzten
rot-grünen bundesregierung war bis 2005
sondern auch 2017 über jamaika
mitverhandelt hat da gab es von den
grünen ein 14 der sondierungsteam und
sie waren teil davon also können auf
sehr viel erfahrung was sind ihre und
koalitionsgespräche angelangt
zurückschauen aber trittin vielleicht
noch ein wort auch zu dem ergebnis
tatsächlich jetzt steht zwar eine
mögliche regierungsbeteiligung natürlich
auf den plan aber fühlt sich das
trotzdem wie ein trostpflaster an nein
ich glaube wir haben es verfehlt die
kanzlerin zu stellen das stimmt auf der
anderen seite gehen wir mit einer fast
doppelt so starken fraktion und einem
klaren wählerinnen und wähler auftrag in
verhandlungen über die bildung einer
neuen regierung für deutschland ich
glaube das ist ein auftrag der sagt in
einer künftigen regierung muss der
klimaschutz im zentrum stehen und da
gehen wir gestärkt rein und insofern
gucken wir jetzt mal nach vorne wo wir
hinkommen wie gut ist denn dieses
strategische lage wenn sie sehen sowohl
armin laschet als auch olaf scholz
relativ schwachen ergebnissen im
vergleich zu dem was frühere kanzler
hatten das heißt grüne und fdp haben
doch eigentlich eine ganz gute
ausgangslage wie wollen sie dass der
nutzen grüne und fdp haben eine gute
ausgangslage aber grüne und fdp haben ja
auch den einen oder anderen widerspruch
in der problematik zu einander ich
glaube aber dass es richtig ist dass wir
jetzt nicht abwarten was die einstmals
großen heute nicht mehr ganz so großen
unter sich ausmachen sondern wir sehr
selbstbewusst in gespräche zwischen der
spd zwischen der fdp und den grünen
eintreten ich glaube allerdings auch
dass in solchen gesprächen natürlich das
wahlergebnis eine rolle spielen wird das
ist das historisch schlechteste ergebnis
was die cdu und die csu überhaupt je
erreicht haben die csu so bisschen jetzt
auf dem niveau der links partei
bundespolitisch gesprochen angelangt das
ist nicht unbedingt ein klarer auftrag
hier dieses land weiter zu regieren wenn
man nach 16 jahren an der regierung ein
solches ergebnis anfangen schauen wir
doch mal auf das prozedere also gestern
wurde ja schon von seiten der fdp aber
auch von seiten beispielsweise von
robert habeck auch von alina weber
gesagt ja bilaterale gespräche mit der
fdp zu führen wäre natürlich durchaus
sinnvoll um schnittmengen aber auch im
knackpunkte erstmal sich anzuschauen
also sind sie dafür zuerst bilaterale
gespräche zu führen oder muss das
parallel laufen auch was gespräche mit
spd und union angelangt hängt ja auch
ein bisschen von der spd oder
gegebenenfalls auch von der union an
dieser stelle ab aber ich glaube dass
wir uns selber überlegen mit wem wir
erst mal reden das ist vernünftig dass
wird auch unserer neuen rolle und so
gewichtige rolle im deutschen bundestag
gerecht das haben wir doch mal wenn sie
jetzt mit der fdp zum beispiel zuerst
reden man kennt sich ja hat gut aus den
jamaika verhandlungen was wird denn
anders sein als vor vier jahren mit der
fdp ich glaube dass die fdp nach vier
jahren im parlament dazu gelernt hat das
war ja ein teil des problems ist für
2017 haben und das zweite teil des
problems war 2017 für die fdp dass sie
zutiefst traumatisiert von den
erfahrungen der vormaligen koalition mit
frau merkel war beides ist jetzt nicht
mehr der fall wir haben beispielsweise
zusammen mit der fdp und übrigens der
linksparteien interessante konstellation
finde ich eine ganz gute arbeit
geleistet um wirecard
untersuchungsausschuss also man kennt
sich und man weiß wie man miteinander
umzugehen hat was ändert nichts daran
dass es natürlich in bestimmten fragen
etwa in der europapolitik in der frage
soll europa weiterhin gegen die krise an
investieren soll es so etwas geben wie
ein recovery fund an green new deal das
in all diesen fragen natürlich schwere
differenzen zwischen den parteien
bestehen wird bei grünen und fdp
natürlich immer darauf verwiesen dass
sowohl in der haushalts und
finanzpolitik auch in der sozialpolitik
durchaus sehr unterschiedliche ansichten
bestehen wenn wir es mal auf die steuer
und finanzpolitik da hat ja christian in
einer quasi schon leitplanken aufgebaut
für mögliche koalitionsgespräche hat
gesagt steuererhöhungen die grünen
wollen beispielsweise sehr gut
verdienende höher besteuern und auch das
aufweichen der schuldenbremse wird es
mit der fdp nicht geben wo kann man da
verhandeln ich glaube solche sachen
werden immer erklärt und wenn man das
genau liest sieht man genau wo die
hintertüren an dieser stelle sind das
sind gespräche die wir jetzt führen
müssen und wir wollen dass es in diesem
lande insbesondere für familien mit
kindern für geringverdiener und nicht
für die oberen eine entlastung gibt weil
wir glauben dass in der pandemie gerade
diese bevölkerungskreise besonders
gelitten haben da muss es eine
entlastung geben und die muss solide
gegenfinanziert werden das kann man
nicht mit haushaltslöchern in der
größenordnung von 90 milliarden das ist
glaube ich das steuerkonzept der fdp
wenn ich es richtig im kopf habe also
ich wenn ich ihnen zuhöre und wenn ich
christian lindner schon gehört habe dann
wird es durchaus ein schwieriger punkt
office erhält man sich hintertüren offen
da ist man da ist man doch immer so dass
in solchen gesprächen erst schwierige
schwierigkeiten gibt wir müssen sich
vorstellen wir sind in einer situation
in deutschland wo aufgrund der
herausforderung der anti demokraten von
rechtsaußen die wieder im bundestag
drinnen sitzen die demokratischen
parteien auch wenn sie in zentralen
fragen unterschiedliche möglicherweise
gegensätzliche auffassungen haben die
verantwortung haben auszuloten ob es
gemeinsamkeiten und kompromisse
möglichkeiten gibt das ist der auftrag
den wir von den wählerinnen bekommen
haben und da führen wir uns erst mal
gestärkt sehen sie jetzt tatsächlich
auch schnelle gespräche wie sinnvoll
wäre das jetzt auch das schnell zu
machen und in welchem kreis soll das
stattfinden sie grün hatten für die
sondierung letztes mal 14 114 der team
für sozusagen die runde
jetzt deutet sich an dass es vielleicht
erst mal ein kleinerer kreis sein könnte
so viel anders auch nicht natürlich hat
es auch da kleinere formate gegeben die
bestimmte sachen vor geklärt haben das
ist auch vernünftig je mehr man
miteinander und je weniger man
übereinander redet umso besser wir haben
das interesse daran dass in dieser
regierung die frage klimaschutz ins
zentrum geschickt wir wollen deutschland
auf den 1,5 grad fahrt bringt das ist
das wofür wir streiken ich muss ihn zum
abschluss noch eine frage zur
innerparteilichen klärung stellen denn
wenn man jetzt schaut nächsten samstag
machen sich schon mal länderrat der
hatte vor vier jahren abgesegnet das ist
ein grünes sondierungsteam gibt und dass
sortiert wird über jamaika jetzt gebe es
ja potenziell zwei möglichkeiten über
ampel oder jamaika zu sondieren wie
sehen sie denn da die grüne basis denn
in einer umfrage in der letzten woche
haben zumindest 75 prozent der
grünen-anhänger gesagt dass sie nicht
für eine jamaika sondierung sind also
welche auseinandersetzungen sehen sie da
in der partei schon gleich zu beginn
also ich habe zur kenntnis genommen dass
eine regierung mit jamaika auf einer
dreiviertel mehrheit abgelehnt wird aber
es gibt überhaupt keine umfrage die
grünen daran hindert zuerst mal fragen
zu sondieren und das ist
selbstverständlich deshalb mit allen
spricht und genau so wird das auch
geschehen vielen dank jürgen trittin
dass die heute morgen zu uns gekommen
sind